[Applause]
um okay I was wondering if you would
play a favorite game of mine there's
some juicy questions inside a bunch of
balloons for Pop Quiz
[Applause]
oh wow wait there we go
I love this oh my God Sam if you love
that you may love to prick something
because giving a good prick is just a
pleasure
I'm scared yes
but it's it's it's it's satisfying isn't
it though slightly sorry
oh thank you I'm excited craziest fan
encounter oh
odd I was outside of venue and they gave
me a saucepan and inside the frying pan
was an envelope and inside the envelope
was a mobile phone
and then on a letter it just said meet
me in the library tomorrow
foreign
absolutely not
but I've always wanted to know what had
what went down at the library I know I
feel like that's kind of like are you
not doing it oh yeah I will I will I I
wanted to give the pleasure because I
get so much pleasure out of this
ah I don't know why it like this is what
gets me excited is popping balloon
who is your first ever celebrity crush
Leonardo Dicaprio and Titanic
100.
pretty sexy there so you're gonna I love
that he's like still clubbing you know
yeah 100 goes on yes you want to answer
this one he goes to the body shop I bet
[Laughter]
yeah naughty naughty boy I know I love
the noise yeah oh if you could be
transformed into any cartoon character
who would it be Ursula
I love that answer
you're good at this thank you I'm now
I'm like doing a different what would
your Spice Girls name be oh chubby
chubby yeah chubby spice
it's a cute thing
or juicy spice juicy juicy spice tea
like cheesy spice
[Laughter]
I'd be naughty spice perfect
perfect
um
would you rather have left would you
rather have legs for arms
or arms for legs
four arms or four legs I suppose it
could I mean I hate feet so I'd have
arms for legs
why do you hate feet I just I would
rather we all had hooves
Centaur yeah they're just so cute
that's so interesting sometimes I feel
like I do have hooves okay
um have you ever had a reoccurring
nightmare
yes since I was a kid I've had this
nightmare that the furniture like the
legs on the furniture get bigger and
bigger and then they all walk out the
room and then it it's weird it's like
it's freaky
and then there's just this furniture
walking around the world
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's such a cool visual I know it is
cool it was in a film recently as well
which was weird so I was like whoa maybe
that person maybe you need to know that
person yeah like it's very Salvador
Dolly okay here oh I've got this
perfect
this is so fun
okay
um
what is one life moment you want to
relive
oh I want to relive picking up my puppy
for the first day
yeah
all right last question here we go
good one okay
oh craziest rumor you've ever heard
about yourself
all right I mean it's just a good one
everyone think everyone seems to think
that I'm Adele
in Drag
because we've never been seen in the
scene in the same room together
and if you slow down her voice
it sounds maybe a bit like mine so
people think that we're the same person
and I'm just in drag right now
okay
and I get asked all the time in every
interview about it and it's really
frustrating how do you feel
it I mean what a fabulous compliment
that I am not Adele
well of anyone to be sunk up with Adele
is amazing Absolutely I'll I'll take it
I you have very different
um talking voices yes yes but from very
we're from different places of the UK
you I I when I I got the pleasure of
hanging out with her once and I was like
oh wow you sound like you're so cool so
cool like she seems so Regal yeah and
like almost unattainable and then you
hang out with her and you're like oh
you're the coolest yeah she really is
she's amazing person well I think maybe
it's that thing that people might think
that you're alike because you're both so
cool and so talented and award-winning
and accoladed and appreciated thank you
and I I love your realness and your
humanity and how that you seem like a
big red Beating Heart and that is how I
want to operate in the world thank you
not putting walls up you do and you
always have we really have I feel like
that's been your journey and that's
other than your magnanimous Talent what
I've been cheering on so much is I feel
like I'm getting to go on a journey of
life with you and if that's not what
we're all trying to do learn how to live
a life together yeah 100 so true thank
you for always inspiring me and being
amazing and this has been a crazy
experience thank you thank you coming
here thank you so
the summer tickets are on sale now
congratulations on your third SNL thank
you
I love you thank you I love you we'll be
right back
[Applause]
[Music]